?
♪ ♪
TREY: THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US I AM TREY GOWDY, SET
SUNDAY NIGHT IN MORK, ONE OF
FIRST LESSONS YOU LEARN IN
THE COURTROOM IS HOW TO
MANAGE EXPECTATIONS, THAT
WILL SERVE YOU WELL IN OTHER
AREAS THAT INCLUDES
POLITICS.
UNDER PROMISE, AND OVER
PERFORM.
THAT IS A GOOD MANTRA BUT IT
RARELY HAPPENS IN POLITICS,
THEY WOULD RATHER TELL YOU
THEY CAN GET A PRESIDENT TO
SIGN THE REPEAL OF A LEASE
OF LEGISLATION NAMES AFTER
HIM.
NO POLITICS IS NOT KNOWN FOR
SETTING PROPER EXPECTATIONS.
BUT WE CAN.
IF REPUBLICANS WIN THE
HOUSE, BUT NOT THE SENATE,
THAT'S THE END OF THE BIDEN
LEGISLATIVE AGENDA,
WHATEVER IDEAS EXIST ON THE
LEFT WILL NOT BECOME LAW,
BECAUSE THEY WILL NEVER SEE
THE FLOOR OF THE HOUSE, THE
MAJORITY CONTROLS THE FLOOR,
IF REPUBLICANS WIN THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE, IT GETS MORE
INTERESTING BECAUSE THEN YOU
WILL SEE THE CONTRAST THAT
USED TO INFORM POLITICS,
THEN REPUBLICAN MAJORITIES
COULD PASS BILLS AND PRESENT
THEM TO PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
HE WOULD VETO THOSE BILLS
BUT AT LEAST YOU WOULD SEE
THE CONTRAST BETWEEN WHAT IS
AND WHAT COULD BE.
THAT CONTRAST WOULD SERVE
YOU WELL HEADING TO ANOTHER
PRESIDENTIAL RACE IN 2024.
REALISTIC EXPECTATION DOES
NOT INCLUDE ANY REPUBLICAN
IDEAS ACTUALLY BECOMING LAW,
IT DOES MEAN DEMOCRAT IDEAS
WILL NOT BECAM LAW IT MEANS
THE END OF WHAT MANY
CONSIDER TO BE BAD IDEAS,
AND STOPPING BAD IDEAS HAS
MERIT IT ISN'T EXCITING
OR GREAT FOR FUND RAISING,
IT WON'T MAKE YOU FAMOUS, SO
MANY POLITICIANS CRAVE THESE
DAYS, THERE IS MERIT
IN STOPPING BAD THINGS.
IF YOUR HOUSE IS ON FIRE, I
DOUBT YOU ARE STANDING IN
THE YARD THINKING ABOUT WHAT
KIND OF NEW KITCHEN COUNTER
TOPPING YOU CAN GET.
I BET YOU ARE THINKING, LET
ME SAVE WHAT I CAN.
LET ME PUT IT OUT AS SOON AS
I CAN, YOU ARE CONTENT
STOPPING THE FIRE.
IF YOU ARE DROWNING, I DOUBT
YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT WHAT
TO WATCHA NETFLIX LITTLE
BITTER THAT NIGHT, YOU ARE
THINKING ABOUT OXYGEN, HELP
AND SURVIVING, YOUR
EXPECTATIONS ARE MODEST BUT
ESSENTIAL.
STOP THE BED, THEN YOU CAN
THINK -- STOP THE BAD, AND
THEN YOU CAN THINK ABOUT
WHAT IS GOOD.
IF YOU WANT HEARINGS ON
CRIME AND INFLATION AND
BORDER AND AFGHANISTAN, YOU
WILL GET THEM, THAT IS A
REALISTIC EXPECTATION.
BUT YOU MAY NOT HAVE YOUR
SUBPOENAS ENFORCED BECAUSE
THAT IS CONTROLLED BY THE
EXECUTIVE AND JUDICIAL
BRANCHES, YOU CAN SET THE
HEARINGS, PICK THE TOPICS
SUBPOENA THE WITNESSES AND
DOCUMENTS, BUT WHAT SHOWS
AND WHAT THEY BRING MAY BE
OUT OF YOUR CONTROL, AND
VOTERS DESERVE TO KNOW THAT.
BE HONEST WITH EXPECTATIONS
ON THE FRONT END AND YOU
WILL BE JUDGED FAIRLY ON THE
BACK-END.
IF YOU EXAGGERATE OR OVER
PROMISE, YOU WILL FAIL, IN
PROCESS BREED ANSWER AND
CYNICISM THAT COMES FROM
UNMET EXPECTATIONS.
THERE IS MERIT IN STOPPING
BAD THINGS FROM HAPPENING.
WHATEVER YOU GET BEYOND THAT
AFTER TUESDAY, LET IT BE A
PLEASANT SURPRISE.
BU